Bishop to C3 was the last move that
we've seen take and take with the B Pawn
wow that's Knight B6 is coming be
careful a remarkable move Rook AB8 was
played so now you see that Wesley
slightly better may be playing for a
victory with the black beast against
Hans nean you have the option of signing
the score sheets basically right now
Knight B6 Rook C7 Knight D5 Rook D7 or
Rook C C8 Knight D6 and then that's your
a draw right you at least eliminate or
very closely eliminating Mishra right at
least for a typ for the gold medal of
course for the gold met or you can also
play this move C5 that was just played
in the position of Pawn sacrifice wow
and throwing the gauntlet immediately
and he says yeah you know what I want to
clinch the title today he's playing C5
and this is a great move best move by uh
the engine by the way